[Musique]
je m'appelle bichancourt stéphane j'ai
52 ans je travaille à l'usiné permaswage
aux clayes-sous-bois je suis tourneur
sur commandes numériques opérateur
régleur depuis 18 ans
j'occupe actuellement la fonction de
opérateur régleur sur l'îlot au numéro 5
mon activité a consisté à faire à
fabriquer des pièces suivant un plan
rien et un programme j'alimente je
décharge et je contrôle les pièces à
100%
les pièces ce sont des raccords
hydrauliques
où passez du kérosène de l'huile suivant
suivant où elle se se met sur un
appareil elles peuvent être droite elles
peuvent être coude et à 45 degrés elles
peuvent être coude et à 90 degrés il
peut y avoir deux branches trois
branches qu'on fait est essentiellement
airbus est la leur actuelle ce sont des
pièces en titane qui sont qui sont pour
le fabricant d'assaut
[Musique]
ce qui est passionnant c'est que on ne
fait jamais la même chose moi j'aime
bien c'est on
on parle on part d'un matrix et donc à
ma tristesse et une pièce brut et on la
finaliste à la fin et on y met à nu mais
de nous mêmes dans la pièce parce que
bon faut qu'elle sorte bonne et on doit
faire très attention à ça
[Musique]
c'était un un coup assez dur parce que
ça cesse du jour au lendemain bah on
nous a dit vous restez chez vous
maintenant que ça va mieux que la
reprise est là c'est très bien
c'est on est content de venir quoi
[Musique]